يوم اسود كما وصفته النقابات التي نظمت
تظاهرات حاشده في اليوم التاسع من
الاحتجاجات الوطنيه ضد قانون التقاعد رد
المعارضه على خطاب الرئيس كان واضحا لا
تراجع حتى تحقيق المطالب بكل ما اوتيت من
قوه حشدت النقابات والاحزاب المعارضه
انصارها في الشارع الفرنسي ردا على خطاب
ماكرون الذي اعلن فيه عن دخول قانون رفع
سن التقاعد حيز التنفيذ في نهايه العام
الجاري
علينا ان نعلمه درسا بان التاريخ ليس
الرئيس من يكتبه بل الشعب والعمال انظروا
من 200 سنه في فرنسا كيف العاملون
والمواطنون هم من كتبوا التاريخ وليس
الرؤساء وكانه اعلنها حربا هكذا اتت رده
فعل متظاهرين في اليوم التاسع للحراك
الوطني لم تقتصر تحركات المحتجين على
المظاهرات المنظمه بل تعدتها الى تعطيل
نقاط رئيسيه عن الحركه في باريس قطع
متظاهرون الطريقه المؤدي الى مطار الرواسي
تشاردو غول في مقطع حمارون محطه قطارات
جاردو ليون وعطلوا سكتها وفي تصعيد اخر
تعدى محتجون على افراد من مركز شرطه مدينه
ما دفع وزير الداخليه الى شجب الاعتداء
وادانته نعم زينه وهكذا انتهى المشهد
حرائق مشتعله في معظم الشوارع بعد قيام
الشرطه بتفريق المتظاهرين الذين انتشروا
في احياء العاصمه وقاموا باشعال الحرائق
لعرقله تقدم الشرطه التي كانت تلاحقهم
وقامت وزاره الداخليه بطلب تعزيزات اضافيه
من قوات الاطفاء مع استمرار المتظاهرين
باشعال الحرائق على طول الطرق والاحياء
التي يسلكونها وبسبب عدد المتظاهرين الضخم
في العاصمه لم تتمكن الشرطه من السيطره
على كل المتظاهرين مشاهد النيران المشتعله
في كل مكان دفعت عددا كبيرا من السكان الى
التحرك ومساعده قوات الاطفاء للسيطره على
هذه النيران هذه المشاهد تذكر بازمه
السترات السفر عام 2018 لكن المعارضه باتت
تقول انها اقوى واعنف لان الرئيس صب الزيت
على النار لقناتي العربيه والحدث فادي
الدهوك باريس